hey everyone welcome to today's video
where we are diving into the exciting
world of devops and charting a road map
for 2024 devops has been reshaping the
way software development and it
operations work together and staying up
to date with the latest trends and
practices is crucial whether you are
season de Pro or just getting started
this road mapap will provide valuable
insights into what to expect and how to
navigate the evolving landscape of
devops in the coming years and before we
begin if you're are someone who is
interested in building a career in
devops by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with devops by
learning from the experts and try giving
a short to Simply learn skel Tech
postgraduate program in devops that is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners this course requires just a
bachelor degree with a 50% average and
no prior programming experience or work
history needed the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
and if these are the types of videos you
would like to watch then hit the
Subscribe button like and press on the
Bell icon to never miss on future
content now starting with what is a DS
engineer a DS engineer is an IT
professional who has an in-depth
understanding of the software
development life cycle they need to
understand why the organization have to
move from one model to the other the
shortcomings of the previous model and
the benefits of the new model and so on
a DS engineer also must know how to use
various automation tools for developing
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipelines this demand
position requires a special set of Dev
skill which we'll explore more in depth
later and now moving on to Career Paths
of DS engineer or a DS professional so
you could be a DS architect or
automation engineer or software tester
or integration Specialist or security
engineer or release manager so these are
the roles a devops professional can play
on or these are the roles that you can
apply for so moving on now we'll see the
career road map for deop engineer so
starting with programming languages then
source code management application
building automation with cicd tool
application testing application
deployment mon application and Cloud
providers so these are the eight steps
you need to follow for a career Ro map
for devs engineer so devs engineer
should be proficient in various
programming languages so we'll start
with number one that is programming
languages so they should be proficient
in various programming languages to
write scripts and automation code for
configuring and managing infrastructure
as well as for customizing cicd
pipelines so these are the programming
languages the skills that needs to be
with Ds engineer now moving on to the
second skill that is source code
management so this involves using
Version Control Systems example kit to
manage source code efficiently Dev
Engineers ensured that code changes
attracted organized and accessible to
the deployment and operation team moving
on to the third one that is application
building so DS Engineers are responsible
for automating the build process they
configure build to tools and scripts to
compile source code into executable
artifacts making it ready for deployment
and then comes the automation with cicd
tool that is continuous integration or
continuous deployment is a core Dev
practice Engineers use cicd tools like
Jenkins or gitlab CI to automate the
testing and deployment of code changes
ensuring a continuous and reliable
delivery pipeline then comes the
application testing automated testing is
crucial for maintaining code quality Dev
Engineers set up and execute various
type of test including unit integration
regression test within the cicd pipeline
and then comes the application
deployment once code passes test de's
engineer automate its deployment to
production and other environments this
step ensures consistency and reduces
deployment errors now moving on to
monitor application so monitoring tools
like promus or elk stack are used to
keep an eye on application performance
and infrastructure help Dev engineer
configure alerts and dashboards to
quickly identify and address issues then
comes the cloud providers DS often
involves working with Cloud platforms
like AWS Azure or Google Cloud Engineers
select the appropriate cloud services
provision resources using infrastructure
as code ISC and manage cloudbased
infrastructure efficiently and if I tell
you in summary the dels road map
encompasses the entire software
development and delivery process it
begins with coding and source code
management followed by automated build
and testing processes automation
continues through cicd tools for
deployment monitoring for performance
and health and leveraging Cloud
providers for scalability and
flexibility this endtoend approach
ensures rapid reliable and efficient
software delivery and I have an
announcement for you guys that is we
offer a DS engineer Masters program in
collaboration with Google Cloud that is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and it requires no
programming experience or no work
history needed our program not only
equips you with the skills but also
prepares you for the industry's most
esteemed certifications making you an
expert in the field you can find this
course Link in the description box below
and the pin commit now moving on to the
roles and responsibility of devs
engineer so devs engineer play a pivotal
role in modern software development and
it operations focusing on enhancing
collaboration Automation and efficiency
throughout the software development life
cycle the roles and responsibilities
include automation that is automating
manual task in the software development
and deployment processes to improve
efficiency and reduce error then comes
the continuous integration or continuous
deployment implementing and managing
cicd pipelines to enable automated and
frequent software releases then comes
the infrastructure escort that is
managing infrastructure using Code
allowing for the automated provisioning
and configuration of resources then
comes the coll collaboration
facilitating collaboration between
deployment and operations teams to
accelerate problem solving and
Innovation then comes the monitoring and
logging implementing monitoring tools to
track system performance analyze logs
and ensure system availability then
comes the security integrating security
practices into the Del's pipeline to
identify and mitigate vulnerabilities
and then comes the release management
that is coordinating software releases
ensuring they meet quality standards and
minimizing down time then comes the
cloud services leveraging Cloud
platforms to enable scalability cost
efficiency and flexibility and then we
have Version Control managing Version
Control Systems to track changes and
facilitate collaboration among team
members and then the role is
documentation that is maintaining
documentation for processes
configurations and best practices to
ensure knowledge sharing and the other
role is problem solving that is
identifying and resolving technical
challenges encountered during the
development and deployment processes and
the last responsibility for DS engineer
is scripting and coding that is writing
scripts and code to automate task and
create custom Solutions and now moving
on to companies hiring DS engineer so
Amazon Cap Gemini Oracle TCS asenta sap
IBM and cognizant these are the major
Giants who hire DS engineer and now
moving on to the average salary for DS
engineer so first we'll see the average
salary in us and that is $882,000 to
$128,000 for a beginner in the US and
for an experienced professional the
salary starts from
$99,000 and it goes up to
$200,000 perom and if we talk about
India the beginners get the average
salary between 5 lakhs to 12 lakhs perom
and if we talk about the experienced
professionals they get salary range from
7 lakhs to 20 lakhs per
and there you have it our deop road map
for 2024 we have explored the key trends
tools and skills that will shape the
de's landcape in the near future now
let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers by opting out
the postgraduate program and the master
program of doops and remember doops is
all about continuous learning and
Improvement so stay curious adapt to
changes and keep horning your skills I
started my It Journey with Accenture 3
years ago I joined there as a cloud
architect there I worked with AWS and
Azure Technologies I was anyway looking
for higher paying jobs and devops seemed
the right career choice so I decided to
go with the postgraduate programing
devops in collaboration with Caltech CME
course was divided into modules and we
had assignments I was really impressed
by how many job interviews I landed
after I added the certification to my
portfolio and now I am earning 40% more
than my previous job didn't only boost
my career but also my confidence if you
found this video helpful don't forget to
like subscribe and share it with your
fellow DS enthusiasts thank you for
tuning in and here's to a successful
Journey along the DS Road in 2024 and
Beyond so till then stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry expert
choose any of our programs and set
yourself on the path to Career Success
click the link in the description to
know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here